hey how the [ __ ] are you doing I mean
how's it going man
we're back and welcome to first stop
awesome
it's not about fisting as you may think
Kevin suggested this game and I took it
from connection
so obviously Tim timber got it
hilarious hi everybody
I'm so glad you could make it what are
they celebrating Manny's wife is hi
we're going to party like it's 1969
that's a sex joke what what's that I
can't even read ha ha ha oh no timber
Thomas no my house my family what in the
name of Jon Bon Jovi's going on I ask
myself that every day
whoa my hand feels odd I think a spider
may have been you the universe needs
your timber [ __ ] is going on ah my hand
is alive
stop shouting ah shut up timber listen
to me Earth's history has been
compromised this is the greatest story
ever
timeline must be restored who the hell
of haul of oats are you why I'm the
mighty fist of awesome will you help me
timber I guess so great I'm taking
control of you're nervous if not nervous
system that means dip mmm this feels
weird
but nice voice effect
man this game has more interactivity
than beyond we can move holy [ __ ]
I fight beers present fist of awesome
it's damn a laka it's walking animation
it is just you see these moves good
that's working fine now I'm going to
punch it why that's racist [ __ ] come in
you a little dear [ __ ] you think your
swagalicious it's what I don't you want
swag Allah sorry I just feel bad every
time I use that word come here
gotta love the sound effect don't you
touch me first blood you knocked out the
first disgruntled man excellent your
mind is most malleable
I'm not how to present happy about this
more dear there you go real piece of
[ __ ] dear got it
the sound effects is impeccable ma ma
hold for fist get up
whoa-ah
brofist yeah Oh kill stay down [ __ ] hey
swipe up to jump
hey tap in air for flying a kick cow I
mean holy deer
wait what did that sign say do not eat
fire I actually try to eat fire one time
I can't recommend hi don't tell me you
didn't try some crazy [ __ ] I know you
you're [ __ ] create love each kill love
nature
in that order yeah oh man sound effects
probably for the entire budget emos take
down your [ __ ] bear hope many
vegetarians aren't watching this I'm
sorry they have to die their [ __ ]
beers okay
oh look it's me it's my Barrett
brett-brett person I tried
get back into filthy hillman keep your
paws off me you damn dirty be well
that's hot
how do I kill you that's [ __ ] easy he
does a lot of barrage man this guy has a
lot about beer that's the best job best
thing hell yeah
bursting see brother Singh is the most
powerful thing in the world breasts you
just got to realize best there we go
yeah [ __ ] is dear
I mean beer sounds beer hat and of
course not mad at ha ha ha it begins you
completed a tutorial ver hatton they
changed it brat
what's the deal with the crazy animals
the course of history has been altered
many species have evolved homicidal and
tendencies bears are now the dominant
species on earth the new state has given
them out of me a little unbearable egos
ha ha ha
maybe they just need a bear hug the puns
are out of control bear grylls get it
goddamnit flame-grilled human flesh that
is just oh hey whoa what's with this
llama holy [ __ ]
bringing hipster beer alright hipster
beer how you go Adam how dare you deny
my hipster attack beer wait that isn't
right
soup of the day tears of our enemy
that's what manly man needs good Bear
Grylls saw me right now he'd be proud
darn proud of my work and my beer is the
best beer in the world beard as a beer
not be here beer would you like to have
shape would you like to shave your beard
with some beers and have a beer
ooh what is oh oh that isn't sexy [ __ ]
mmm can I go in here ah bear beer I just
threw up in my mouth
stop that I can taste what you taste
that means he can taste my dick when I
nothing okay uh how do I go in to bear
beers would you like some bear B would
you like to shave your bear your would
you like to shave your beard bear with
some beer with your bearable beer
[ __ ] oh just a [ __ ] [ __ ] come here
right let me [ __ ] you you never trusted
best throw so fluffy
you think they're cute then they'll eat
you no other animals besides sharks
no one said like Isaac your charcoal
just gonna hand no one fears the loo
that [ __ ] they'll trick you the sons of
[ __ ] that's why they made it this far
in in the evolution how dare they dried
a moustache Riku and I'll we'll see
about that
look at that poster I'm fat famous I
thought is it fabulous [ __ ] yeah wanted
timber why do bears want to eat and kill
me so far you punch every one of them
they started it that's very true that's
very true this well I'll never forget it
how does beers fit in genes anyway
doesn't make any sense
stay down [ __ ] man look at those
graphics this is like the next Call of
Duty machete that's a better story than
Twilight and better graphics and Call of
Duty there has to be the best game I
have ever played if it wasn't for all
the [ __ ] beers
let's try some fisting best days pistons
you want some fasting up yours fast I
don't deny my friend you like fisting
best yo yo [ __ ]
why your [ __ ] so wide whatever gap oh
no it's an afro bear they're quite rare
in men it'd be Ratan idiot human you're
looking for trouble me nope no trouble
hair thanks though this is art if you
must pick hey well then that seems fair
it's your turf after all taxes ripping
beating hard from chest
oh [ __ ] well he said it seemed fair so I
guess we gotta let me do it just Patek
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
get out get out my god damn it he got me
that son of a [ __ ] guard me girls don't
watch this bagra's is gonna unsubscribe
for my channel Shh gotta make it look
good man I love bear grylls he's like
the cool carry shut up all right let's
piston fess em fess some I fitted me I
liked it I liked it oh [ __ ] no don't
don't don't don't die you die son of a
[ __ ]
okay we level up at least level up yeah
what is this pet this special we need
more power she must have more power you
got dead thank you sir thank you okay
we just have to redo the bus all right
this is focus focus aggro more dots more
dots Tom and the fights intense it's
been lasting for days how do I survive
okay now we got him one more one more
handed [ __ ] is this mine let's get
his ass scattered us from behind yes
that's how you kill an afro beer sorry
don't mean to rear aces you cleaned the
streets of beer head and yeah let's get
some help
let's continue looking good champ well I
thank you sir
humans ooh what the [ __ ] oh man that guy
what CIA
what's going on here Gareth Thomas the
greatest dancer the most fabulous man on
planet
hey it's definitely indie developers
caution extreme danger oh [ __ ]
hey you're not allowed here so this is
like for the toilets no toilets leave
now but it's an emergency I'm touching
clothes ha ha ha ha
filthy human I will flush you away bear
fine hell yeah I want everything exactly
the same except the puns are different
and the skins are different ha ha ha
don't die ok don't die super Sayan what
check out 100 Pelican beers do you even
eat beer and everything I ate a beer but
I gotta eat a beer after this not even
legal can you die Kenny die
can you die I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
if I don't move oh [ __ ] ok
nail that you nail that no good can come
oh yeah let's go intern - what is that
thing a Lawrence and Traverse in the
worm ha I love deserves its eggs bill is
funny walk ok it looks safe let's go
hell yeah
Yolo am i right hell yeah level
holy [ __ ] so many levels yeah alright
let's get some health and power I don't
really need only out of [ __ ] alright I
think we I think we get the gist of it
by now it's a pretty cool game I hope we
was enjoy watching live it like if you
did helps me out a lot
it's a scar a coma red today and I'll
see you in the next one sound some
breath love you ha ha oh oh oh I'm
inside my god that wasn't on Dean
love doesn't turn into cute